do you want to find out how to make the
most beautiful stunning engaging
portraits of your friends or yourself
using just your phone camera and no
special apps we'll look no further than
this video because I'm about to show you
right now see what you do is take your
camera you go over to Kenan would look
up and when I said go slowly took your
head down my favorite movie expressions
you face go they tilt their head you
pano across the face only move and they
just end up being a thing of beauty just
dude christian how could how could
anyone not fall in love with a beautiful
face like that this video really teach
you how to make panels we're back here
in pasadena to visit Casey Edwards our
friend and composer we're gonna workout
in round 2 of the corridor EP that's
right it took us this long to get back
together since you saw the last video
but you know what we got one track going
already it's pretty sweet I can't wait
to lay down some lyrics
I brought some here I'm excited I hope
you guys are guys be careful of over
influencing it's deadly out there we
just saw a homeless man who used to be a
youtuber named Toby Turner it was bad
anyway I don't want to get bogged down
in thank you buddy I think the point is
just hashtag no ooi everybody know and
everyone's good yeah do you haven't you
heard of the dangers I have we want to
get out the word I'm like how over
influencing can be deadly if you try to
influence people to not be over
influenced then all of a sudden you've
influenced them over in
well that's why it's so important that
we hear over it you don't even notice it
oh dude influence privilege
dude check that [ __ ] I'm so sorry you
guys I didn't know these your stomach
hurt I've heard that also oh I can lead
to really bad diarrhea sigh dude you've
been asking your viewers don't even know
what the dial up sounds are yeah but you
know what I think we gotta also gotta
ask ourselves who are we making this out
before right I'm okay with the dialogue
yeah I mean it was like that
hey yo mmm this is a paul
rosenstein-rodan here and we're gonna
see what happens see a real house last
time we did like a rough idea for
possible tracks yeah I know I think we
should just focus on one for a bit and
check out the kind of words you guys
having right now
I agree I have this beat and I have some
ideas but I want to hear the flow first
yeah he wanted his truck and jump into
this do I need to do like some push up
or something first I feel like you can't
just like I can't just like listen up
the SUBSCRIBE hardest rap lyrics from
the blast
history of mankind
ten push-ups hey wait if I do push-ups
more than what I owe
per day for my debt no I don't get I
don't get credit I haven't have a
push-up mortgage yeah I owe 45 a day to
the end of the year yeah things happened
I went places when you use the panorama
tool there's basically a line where
things are being captured you can kind
of see it if you're like wiggling the
phone back and forth removing your hand
you can see there's a line where it's
cutting off and it's capturing things
use that line and move things right on
that border if it's being captured just
like let's say we're capturing my face
and they're scanning down my face this
is that line where it's being captured I
started moving my face it's going to
warp it and it's using that trick and
those shifts in perspective and warping
to get really weird-looking things how
Michael you're getting a new profile
picture haha all right we're gonna do
the classic camera here so we're gonna
start with you looking up and I'm going
to scan from the bottom up so basically
he's going to turn his head in the
opposite direction I'm singing when
looking for is that little wine
where things are being captured once
that starting to cross his chin I'll say
go and he's gonna tilt his head down
slowly while I slowly scan of his face
yeah that's gonna be a weird one that's
a 3/4 angle oh I see where we're good
the best thing is the backgrounds turn
out looking normal
but people's faces dude Carmichael this
time would you go with me so start down
and as I scan the chin he's gonna move
his head up no I may have messed that
one up but you know what there are no
mistakes
Pano's but I must disturb you for the
sake of entertainment for everybody else
I'm going to scan from the bottom up and
Jake's going to move his head in the
opposite direction so it gives them a
concave face
[Applause]
and if I can make it to a 100 I'm gonna
scan from bottom up and when I do till
your head upwards okay filling up with
air what am i when I was a little boy in
heaven Annette I used to use
encyclopedias to check my facts until
the day uppers connected to that World
Wide Web and switch my indexes for
search terms instead spent the next 20
years just straight balling learning it
all until my connection started crawling
did a hard reboot from one signal to
another and then I got a call from my
mother she said
Jake I'm trying to email your little
brother and every time I hit Send I'm
interrupted by your father telling me my
whole connection is malignant in the
line but I don't understand my
computer's working fine hum nothing but
my break in my heart starts creaking
nobody even that connection had been
true and now his cheating mistreating
Tom Warner is about to take a big cuz a
man without a web is like the king
without a queen and everything just blew
up mujahideen and then that diverse you
know just like it keeps going that's
great we got a lot to work with yes
we're laying this down okay do you I'm
ready
so while you're recording you're not
gonna be able to hear me which is fine
we're gonna do some jr. oh yeah hey that
was a good that was a good tape it's
okay I'll just poke my head out so
you're gonna want that clean you ready
to throw it on some tracks dude I would
be except I'm going to yoga right now
we're making merlyn's music right you
guys are just thinking about how the
internet doesn't work yeah man
you either sing about honey it's not
working what's your what's your name
getting collectively we're Casey Edwards
in the algorithms I think were going to
be DJ Cletus Cletus all right we'll see
if it's up to you man you get that
section of the title chunk you see the
sidewalk surfers that's not bad
nothing bad at all my nickname in high
school is a phat skateboarder is my old
lion I didn't give myself that nickname
I'm not like hey I'm fat
own it man the biggest schmuck you to
all those peoples to name yourself
chunky see man yeah all right so you can
also do full body shots let's do one of
those we're gonna do a tiny Jake
standing next to a regular Christian so
officials in a stand there he's going to
be just Latinos does not move and he'll
look normal in the panorama but as I
scan Jake is going to lower himself down
until I tell him to stop we're gonna
hold it and I wanted to be looking up at
Christians now it's important that Jake
stays directly facing the camera it'll
look like just totally normal legs I
mostly got it so there's a tiny Jake
these are a little bent you can kind of
see it and then there's a normal-sized
Christian next we got a tiny Jake you
can also make those necks really long
Jake's gonna start low you know I tell
him he's going to slowly rise without
moving
[Music]
the back of the background looks
complete normal yeah it makes these
looks at using cyclopædia to check my
facts until the day uppers connected to
that way from one signal - for another
and then I got a call from my butt into
this I'm so glad this is happening by
the way
DJ meniscus or something like little
little menisci lakhs of litres buckets
DJ bucket yeah mustn't let me get the
bucket of beers dude the shot it's just
pretty friggin like the pop filter and
then houses then collapses dude shades
hard shades
it must've lovely at the bucket a bit
you have to wear shades that's how you
know it's me mess my hair up a little
bit like I'm a hard-working artist yeah
just produce some beats I'm gonna shut
the door you're gonna hear four clicks
and it's just gonna hit feel free to
wait in the amount of time because I can
drag the vocals wherever one get alright
and everything I know just blew what who
shot Dean when I was a little boy didn't
having a net I used to use encyclopedias
to check my back until the day I first
connected to that world work well and
swish my indexes for search terms in
steps
[Music]
stop so I want you guys to take some
Panos and I want to see them so go ahead
and post them on the corridor subreddit
are / corridor so I can go check them
out I think all of us in the office here
will be heartily laughing at what you
come up with if you're not subscribed to
the channel please consider doing so and
if you want to be really on top of
things hit that little notification icon
YouTube's been a little iffy with
showing people who are subscribed the
videos are actually subscribed to you
can avoid all that by turning on your
notifications thanks
[Music]